put your tray table up and your seats in
the upright position ladies and
gentlemen because we have manifests the
love child of lost and this is us which
promises its fair share of emotion and
mystery but while lost left some viewers
disgruntled and searching for answers
manifest creator Jeff rake has promised
there is a mystery endgame here join me
in this new series as we aim to tackle
the mysteries behind flight eight to
eight on April 7th 2013 flight eight to
eight from Montego Bay to New York
experiences a sudden weather surge which
causes major turbulence and panic but
it's short-lived and the flight
continues as normal when the plane lands
however we learn it's no longer 2013
rather November 4th 2018 on board our
brother and sister bacala and penn stone
as well as Ben's son Cal they reunite
with their family who believed them dead
for five and a half years Mikaela begins
to hear a strange voice in her head
first she saves a kid from being hit by
a bus then she finds two kidnapped girls
in a metal container but she soon finds
out it's not just her hearing the voice
but also her brother and everyone else
on the flight and that's when the plane
explodes so what's going on what
happened with the plane and more
importantly what is happening to the
passengers first let's go over theories
on what happened to the plane and how
could possibly shown up five years later
number one the Bermuda Triangle one of
the great mysteries of the ocean the
Bermuda Triangle or The Devil's Triangle
is known for taking thousands of lives
without a trace some believe it to be
the cause of paranormal activity the
origin of Atlantis or even aliens take a
look at a map of the flight from Montego
Bay to New York you'll notice the plane
flies directly over you guessed it the
Bermuda Triangle
the writers could have chosen a flight
from anywhere in the world but they
purposely selected Montego Bay Jamaica
to New York theory number two an act of
God religion plays a big part in the
first episode we have the Bible quote
from the book of Romans found on the
pillow which is the same as the address
in the junkyard
and coincidentally is the same number as
the flight it's an act of God the storm
surge which wasn't picked up by radar
that was the catalyst for the show and
potentially an act of God which made the
plane explode at the end with
all the passengers watching did
something not want the government
prodding it for clues or did it want to
send some sort of message theory three a
wormhole a wormhole is a theoretical
passage through space-time that could
create shortcuts for long journeys
across the universe in this case it
would have created a rift bending time
and sending the passengers five years
into the future but if this were the
case what or who caused it is still
unknown honestly this isn't my personal
theory but it should at least be
mentioned which brings me to my next
question what are the voices shortly
after being released by the FBI Michaela
begins to hear a voice her voice but
somehow also not it starts while
embracing her sister-in-law Grace when
she hears all things then slow down on
the bus and finally set them free with
the dogs of course them is not referring
to the dogs rather the two girls trapped
in this dude storage container it seems
as though whatever happened on that
flight gave the passengers the power to
predict danger or is it something trying
to guide them as I stated earlier
there's a heavy religious presence in
the show right off the bat Mikayla's mom
mentions her favorite bible verse all
things work together for good more
precisely and we know that all things
work together for good to those who love
God to those who are called according to
his purpose this passage shows up
multiple times in the episode and is
taken from you guessed it Romans 8 to 8
something was calling Michaela to the
workshop and then again for all the
passengers to the plane take a look at
the verse one more time and we know that
all things work together for good to
those who love God to those who are
called according to his purpose it's
when Michaela asks how do we know if
we're called that she gets the trigger
calling her to the plane when this
character a man will come to know is rad
plays the violin and is called he's
playing a song called meditation from
the Opera tastes in the scene in which
this song is played two characters
confront a us a beautiful and hedonistic
courtesan of Venus and attempt to
persuade her to leave her life of luxury
and find salvation through God the
metaphor of finding salvation through
God being a possible connection to the
show and especially the verse from
Romans what if everyone is dead and in
purgatory that's right the classic lost
theory everyone
iDEN is now being tested by God or a
higher power the test revolving around
the voices they hear and likely will
hear in future episodes or more likely
they are alive but something is trying
them but why do these people need to be
tested at the beginning of the episode
Mikayla says funny how one little
decision could ruin your life but also
save it implying by the end of the story
she receives Redemption later we learned
that she's convinced she murdered Evie
in her car despite a judge deeming her
innocent is this what Mikayla needs
redemption from and where does that
leave Ben what's in his closet is it
about how he made his six sons so
desperate for his attention or will his
tests involve the partner Grace's kept
hidden from him during his five-year
absence and what will happen once
everyone realizes they're all hearing
voices let me leave you with one more
point
mrs. stones favorite passage all things
work together for good
maybe the passengers only hope of
finding out what happened and
potentially getting back to their
timeline relies on them working together
those are just some of the mysteries
beginning to unfold in this series if
you want me to continue exploring
manifests make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and I love hearing your
theories in the comment section
stay tuned